u.s surgeon general and vice admiral
jerome adams joins us now he's a member
of the white house coronavirus task
force
dr adams it's really good to see you
let's start where david left off with
the schools
there's backlash in florida and as a
you're a doctor of course you're also a
father
what needs to happen for schools to
reopen safely and i realize
different states have different needs
but generally speaking
what needs to be done for the schools to
be okay for kids to go back this august
of this september well good morning gail
and thank you for that question as you
mentioned i have a 16 a 14 and a 10 year
old so this is very personal
to me and what i want people to know is
the biggest
determinant of whether or not we can go
back to school actually has
little to nothing to do with the actual
schools it's your background
transmission rate
and it's why we've told people
constantly that if we want to get back
to school
to worship to uh to regular life
folks need to wear face coverings folks
need to practice social distancing
those public health measures are
actually what's going to lower the
transmission rate and we've seen in
norway
we've seen in denmark when they start
with a low background transmission rate
they were able to safely reopen schools
with minimal
to no transmission among young people
particularly people under the age of 10
or 12. now
cdc has recommendations what do you say
what do you say though doctor
yeah go ahead go ahead no i said cdc has
recommendations for things that you can
do
in schools but again the most important
thing is what we do
outside of schools before we reopen to
lower the transmission rate
the government has a role but i want
people to understand we as individuals
have a role too
to do what we can and that includes
wearing face coverings
okay but you've still got teachers
you've still got parents that say
wearing face coverings
do you think that's really it if your
kids go back to school and they have
face coverings
you think that's that's safe enough oh
no gail that that's
part of the equation when you're in
school what i'm saying is we need to be
doing that now
before school is open so that we can
lower the transmission rate in schools
we also have to protect the older people
the teachers
the uh the family members that these
students may live with because we know
that the risk is low
to the actual students but we know that
they can transmit to
others and so i don't want to in any way
shape or form either diminish
the potential impact to teachers and we
need to take measures to make sure we
can protect those
who are vulnerable either because
they're older or they have chronic
medical conditions
let's talk about testing because we
still seem to have issues with the
testing and now it appears the white
house doesn't want to support extra
funding for testing what's the thinking
behind that
well what i can tell you from our
deliberations on the task force
are that in the last bill there was 10
billion with the b
dollars allocated for testing and only
about 36 million
with an m has been drawn down from that
fund so some of the
the debate is not about whether or not
we need more testing or need more or
need more of that in in communities but
it's really about whether or not
we've even spent the money that's
already been allocated i think we all
agree particularly the physicians on the
task force
that we need to have more testing more
uh more
contact tracing more isolation uh but uh
but again we also have to have a lower
community
prevalence rate and i hate to keep
harping but the american people i need
you to hear me
testing isolation and contact tracing
doesn't work when you've got
out of control spread in communities and
so we need to understand that the way we
get all of this to function
is by getting people to commit to
wearing face coverings to not
getting in crowded gatherings to
maintaining six feet of social distance
that lowers the prevalence and
everything else starts to function
do you think the president is finally on
board about wearing a mask he seems to
be changing his messaging on that
well i'm a physician not a political
pundit and it doesn't do me any good to
get back and back and forth about the
president what i can tell you is i'm
very pleased
that he actually is now uh wearing a
face covering
uh medically he's tested more than
anyone
so from a medical standpoint i
understand why he chooses
not to but but i'm glad that he has said
that this is a patriotic thing to do
that supports your freedom it's
something i've been saying for four
months now
all right and the task force briefings
are going to resume today
will you dr fauci and dr burks be in
attendance
well they're still figuring that out i
know that as they resume
we will be there in our different roles
as folks know i'm a strong advocate for
making sure we are promoting the
the awareness of the impact on
communities of color particularly
african americans and particularly
hispanics
all right so maybe we'll see you later
this afternoon at the briefing thank you
very much dr adams
for your time this morning thank you
gail